name a more iconic duo than change in
eSports oh wait
additions and tweaks are made to eSports
titles all the time with something
changes nearly every week new characters
items levels they're all added to the
game to make it more interesting for
both casual players and hardcore fans
but one change made to csgo helps enter
the game itself change the way
organizations structure their rosters
and put an emphasis on players who could
lead their teams from the frontlines in
[Music]
August of 2016
valve dropped a bombshell of a ruling on
the csgo community limiting the way
coaches could talk to their players
in-game quote during a match the coach
may only communicate with the players
during warm-up halftime or during one of
four 30-second time outs that the coach
or players can call now that might not
sound so bad out of context but there's
something you have to understand before
the ruling coaches were totally
unrestricted and how they could talk to
their players and that was the standard
four years prior even before global
Offensive back in the days of 1.6 and
source' coaches had free rein to talk to
and direct their players whenever they
wanted but they were limited to standing
behind them and gleaning whatever
information they could from watching
their screens
but csgo brought a new innovation to the
game a spectator mode with special
coaching features that allowed coaches
to spectate their players from inside
the game provided they were given their
own dedicated PC and event this feature
allowed coaches to see and hear
everything their players saw and heard
and it gave him a much clearer picture
of what was going on in the game
spectator mode elevated coaches
abilities to make a strategic call and
as the feature became more ubiquitous a
simple question began to emerge why
bother with a bottom fragging in-game
leader when you could just pick up
another aim star and get your coach to
make all the calls this mindset played a
role in how organizations built their
rosters from around 2015 to 2016
gobby for example was removed from
mouths sports and replaced by speedy
Zeus was kicked from na defense air and
replaced by simple swimmy exited cloud9
with automatic taking his place and
ninjas in pyjamas were being transformed
under the leadership of coach threat and
even the entire concept for the old g2
super team roster the one that was later
sold to faze clan was birthed from this
brawn over brains mentality in the
meantime csgo was getting bigger and
like in any growing game organizations
started building up support staff to get
an edge in the competition
coaches analysts trainers nutritionists
you get the idea
they provide relief to the players and
then the players level of play improves
or so the theory goes it's just like in
any traditional sport you got coaches
and you got more support staff and you
got more people helping you do your job
right so I can I just talk to you know
you got physical trainers and you know
offensive coaches defensive poses and
assistant coaches in Counter Strike I
thought part of what was gonna be cool
about having coaches and stuff is that a
couple of things happen when you have a
coach one it makes it so the players
playing can focus more in their game so
yeah you make it so there's more skilled
players in the game right and more
people that like strategy and have a
mind for strategy can focus only on that
and don't have to play at the same time
so those are the benefits despite that
Valve clearly felt like the direction of
competitive csgo was straying too far
from what they had intended for the game
for instance valve never allowed coaches
to have their own dedicated spectating
pcs during majors even though it was a
valve who introduced those features in
the first place the way that I see it is
that Valve have already made it
perfectly clear to the players that they
don't want to the Sixth Man to be the
in-game leader right they don't want the
coach to be that involved in the game
and they made this months ago right they
bit they they basically made it clear
they even made it so that tou know
tournament organizers TOS you know not
give pcs for example to the coach you
know that the coach should just be
standing there behind the players you
know if anything you know that they
shouldn't have their own PC to be able
to look in game etc you know they've
made it pretty clear it seems now for
quite some time that the teams shouldn't
have that in-game leader be the six men
the company's philosophy on coaching was
further elaborated on after the Columbus
major when former Team Liquid coach GB
James met with found developers to pick
their brains about the future of the
csgo competitive scene relating is
meeting with a valve devs and at wit
longer he said the coach spec option in
game took off more than they originally
intended they want to protect the
integrity of the 5v5 team experience for
the lower level who do not have touches
essentially they want viewers at home
who play the game to be watching the
same game that they play at home
three months later valve finalized their
decision and laid down the walls during
a match the coach may only communicate
with the players during warmup during
halftime or during one of four 30-second
timeouts that the coach or player can
call obviously third-party events can
use whatever rules they want but if you
want to align your events with ours than
recommend using this code several
thousand tensions were made clear and
the CS community was not happy about it
at the heart of Valve's argument was a
desire to preserve the 5v5 team format
of csgo that the fans were getting in at
home
Bob wanted fans to feel like the only
thing that was separating them from the
pros was skill not outside influences
like a six man who oversaw every play
needless to say that coaches themselves
took issue with this new rule as well
but despite protests coming from all
sides of the cs community valve doubled
down making a public announcement
reaffirming their new rule set and
rebutting any allegations that they
didn't communicate their intentions
effectively with the competitive
community valve in their eyes they've
seen they've given the players time to
make adjustments the players haven't
made adjustments or not really they've
kind of kept doing what they wanted and
so valve a finally decided right if
you're not gonna make the adjustments
we're gonna force you to make the
adjustments there we go and so we'll see
where we go from there it's important to
note that technically valve the rules
only affected the majors and the miners
and unaffiliated tournament organizers
to do whatever the hell they wanted but
since the majors are the bedrock that
the entire csgo competitive scene is
built on the rule still had an effect on
how teams built their rosters all of a
sudden some of those teams that drop
their IG ELLs and what their coaches
take the reins we're in serious trouble
but despite disruption from Val
rulz other affected teams were still
able to find success liquid and Navi for
example both teams with high profile
coaches and starix and peacemaker were
both in attendance for the first
tournament to use a new rule set ESL one
New York 2016 well both had poor results
in the lead up they defied expectations
advancing past the swiss group stage
with navi going undefeated the CIS squad
went on to beat liquid in the semis and
won the entire event nearly gets caught
but not every team weathered the storm
ninjas in pyjamas a legendary name and
counter-strike failed to qualify for the
first host coaching ban major in Atlanta
in many ways vows new rules diminished
the roles of coaches to a point where it
seems like they're even less essential
than they were in 1.6 at source but
while some in the communities theorized
that coaches were at risk of losing
their jobs they had overlooked IG ELLs
who already out of work or close to it
prior to the coaching change with the
advent of coach spectating in-game
leaders are being pushed out of top
teams and replaced by more mechanically
skilled players but Valve's coaching man
ensured the necessity of in-game leaders
on all top level teams and there's talk
about strike back leave was one such igl
that stepped up after the rule change
leading a straw louis to a major victory
in Atlanta the first major for the
Danish team even Kerrigan the leader who
has kicked off of a straw 'lest found
his redemption when he took over as
phase clans igl and let's not forget to
Zeus who after being left behind by Navi
went on to win the Krakow major with
gamma-d stones while Mao's sudden and
drastic change may have ushered in
for coaches it was a huge chandi arm for
that rare breed of player who can call
the strats and frag with the rest of the
team a lot can be said about how valve
handled the coaching rule from both
sides of the issue and it's tempting to
imagine a world where the coaching ban
never took effect would pro cs be more
dynamic more strategic more exciting if
it were just five fraggers on a team
with an omnipotent coach calling all the
strats maybe but it's been nearly two
years since the ban was implemented and
it doesn't seem like the rule is
changing anytime soon
when it comes to Valve's games what they
say goes thanks for watching if you want
more great content just like this be
sure to hit the subscribe button
[Music]